una de las mejores maneras de aprender
es enseñando a otros
si tienes que explicar algo a alguien
más eso te ayudará a entenderlo mejor
ayudarías a uno de los miles de
estudiantes nuevos aprendiendo
programación aquí en can academy cada
uno de ellos se beneficiaría del
conocimiento que ahora tienes tenemos
tres maneras geniales en las que puedes
ayudar y las iré en seguida durante este
curso has tenido tanto desafíos como
proyectos los desafíos han sido
calificados automáticamente por hopper
pero los proyectos son más libres y
creativos de manera que no es tan fácil
calificar los automáticamente en lugar
de eso tenemos gente real haciendo
evaluaciones personas como tú que saben
programar y quieren ayudar a otros
si quieres evaluar proyectos solo ve a
la página de inicio y presiona sobre
evaluaciones de proyecto
encontrarás solicitudes de evaluación de
proyectos a la mitad de la página y
puedes escoger tus proyectos favoritos
para evaluar o solo empezar por los
primeros cuando evalúas verás una
rúbrica y deberá decidir si el proyecto
cumple con el objetivo o no si no lo
cumple puedes darles ideas de las
maneras en que pueden alcanzar el
objetivo
los proyectos son un proceso intermedio
el estudiante tiene que seguir
trabajando en ellos hasta que alcancen
los objetivos así que las evaluaciones
les ayudarán a entender lo que tienen
que mejorar al final de la evaluación
puedes dejar comentarios y es un gran
lugar para decir cosas lindas y
motivarlos para seguir adelante con la
programación y oye si te impresiona
algún proyecto vota por el estamos
sorprendidos con algunas cosas locas y
geniales que hacen todos ustedes en sus
proyectos algunas veces cuando estás
programando algo de at horas tal vez no
logras averiguar cómo dibujar un
espagueti con la loca función versión o
no puedes lograr que winston rebote bien
a través de la pantalla en momentos como
ese puede solicitar ayuda pedir ayuda a
la comunidad
si quieres tratar de responder preguntas
como esa sólo ve a la página principal
de programación de computadoras y
presionen solicitudes de ayuda verás las
solicitudes más recientes hasta arriba y
puedes navegar hasta encontrar alguna
que esté a tu nivel y oye también puedes
solicitar ayuda en tus propios programas
definitivamente creemos que los maestros
pueden ser estudiantes y los estudiantes
pueden ser maestro
al mismo tiempo tal vez te des cuenta de
que puedes aprender mucho solo leyendo
las respuestas de otras personas para
hacer eso solo presiona en la pestaña de
respuestas para ver las que ya se han
respondido y puedes leer eso por horas
recuerda cuando veías las guías paso a
paso y tenías una pregunta tal vez
buscabas en las preguntas para ver si
alguien tenía la misma duda quizá te
hiciste la pregunta y afortunadamente
alguien la respondió ahora puedes ayudar
a las personas que están preguntando
solo ve a la página principal de
programación de computadoras y presiona
en preguntas de la comunidad y podrás
navegar a través de las preguntas más
recientes y encontrar una en la que
creas que tienes la respuesta entonces
ahí está hay muchas maneras en que
puedes ayudar a los nuevos programadores
a aprender y si tal vez te sientas muy
nuevo programando pero en realidad sabes
más que el 99% de la población mundial
así que no te quedes con ese
conocimiento solo para ti